all right people we are live on YouTube
and the Facebook and we have a
last-minute booking here at the Rubin
report mister Maajid Nawaz has joined us
live in studio we're meeting for the
first time I can't believe it what I was
just saying to you David that I remember
being your second ever interviewee I
think the other went Sam me and then I
on close enough and then and then your
show kicked off yeah I'd like to take
the credit beam in the middle there for
some of the some of the early days of
your success but the kid kidding aside
is a pleasure to finally meet you yeah
well it's a pleasure to sit here with
you but I am gonna give you credit for
something because people constantly
credit me with coming up with the phrase
of regressive left yeah you get that one
cleared up I wanna meet one severe I say
it on silly guys yes I don't popularize
it obviously yeah yeah I want to be very
clear looking directly in your eyes you
were the one who came up with the phrase
yeah regressive for my sins
it's in my autobiography radical from
2012 I kind of started using it around
2011 that there is a you can look at
these things search online there's
there's a reference to regressive before
that of course because that's a word in
the English language there is no
reference to the word in the construct
regressive left used in the way it's
used here to describe precisely what
we're trying to describe and that is
cultural relativism as deployed by those
who call themselves left-wing and
weaponized against those who are
attempting to challenge cultural
relativism within the left wing and that
specific reference to that meaning
I don't think existed before I used in
that way in radical but but again the
concept existed yeah and so I wouldn't
take credit for inventing the idea how
important our words in in this way
because we're going to talk about a lot
of words you're going to talk about some
definitions yeah
Islamist in jihadist and all of the
things that obviously you're talking
about all the time but do you find like
that phrase regret still that to me the
reason I used it a lot was because
people had these thoughts they were
realizing something was was wrong there
with the so-called liberals yeah and the
phrase it just can't just work and
and it really showed me the power of
words when you're yeah discussing things
like this gave the power of words is
something which I've been into as people
who know my story would know I've been
into hip-hop from around the age of 12
11 onwards and that first taught me the
power of words and in fact it we're in
the West Coast right so NWA
coming straight from LA in from Compton
yeah that Straight Outta Compton was
what it was called um and what kind of
dinner Jason and the power of those
words in defiance at you know if the
police aren't you know I don't know I
swear on your show or not but you can I
mean [ __ ] the police was the track that
I really got into at the age of around
13 and it spoke to me in such a powerful
way because it was in those days times
and I was being arrested and harassed by
the Essex police authorities eventually
ended up being arrested at gunpoint by
them profiling all that sort of stuff so
I learnt from an early age that words
and articulating our words in a precise
and concise way can be so powerful in
bringing meaningful change so there is
some sometimes a danger of overusing
regressive left but there's a concept
that I after leaving and fast forwarding
now after leaving my former Islamist
group Hezbollah yeah which only
reinforced by train my stint in his but
to her only reinforced to me the power
of words and the power of correct
articulation of concepts for the
purposes of spreading ideas so that only
reinforced what we because they were
using so yeah absolutely Islamists are
very very well aware of the power of
words especially in what they called our
which is proselytization and the
importance of words in dour and
proselytization even theologically is
grounded when i often distinguish
between Islamism and islam and we can
come to that you know even religiously
not just for Islamists but the power of
words is recognized in the Islamic
religion for the importance of Dawa or
proselytization it's something which
anyone who's got a message to get across
is going to need to understand so after
leaving his Battaglia I came across this
idea that was doing that used during the
Cold War and it's called semantic
infiltration and it was all about not
allowing for your enemies
propaganda to infiltrate your language
so that you begin having a conversation
on their terms of reference huh this is
fascinating because they see a lot of
this right now yeah yeah and so that's
called semantic infiltration and it's a
danger to allow that to happen so to
give you an example of that in a field
that we're familiar with are so it's
lists in one sentence a definition for
that those who want to impose a version
of Islam over Society which is commonly
known as theocracy but a Muslim version
of that theocracy let's call it Islam
isn't we can get to the wisdom of these
terms what is the difference between
Islamism and fundamentalist Islam and
all of that we can get to that yeah
butBut Islamists believe that their view
on Islam ie that it must be enforced on
everybody first off in Muslim majority
societies and then in the rest of the
world they believe that is Islam and
they believe therefore by definition
they speak for Islam and Muslims so when
they speak they speak in that way and
they say the Islamic ruling of or for
you know whatever a Caliphate is this X
Y and Zed now the danger is that if
we're attempting to isolate Muslims
Islam is from everyday ordinary Muslims
if an Islamist is claiming to speak as a
representative of what Islam is and
monopolizing that definition of Islam
the danger with semantic infiltration
here is a concept that first Arosa said
with the USSR in America they were
concern about adopting communist
language and communist terms of
reference when trying to undermine
communist propaganda
you've already ceded the ground right so
if then when an Islamist says this is
what Islam says if we then accept that
as a given and begin engaging in that
conversation on their terms of reference
we've already ceded the ground yeah so
that language is crucial so that puts
the the nominal the phrase nominal I
don't really like people say the nominal
Muslim and it's something that I think
is not quite appropriate but the average
person who of course is as peaceful and
freedom-loving and just wants to have a
job and a family and food and all of the
things that ever one else in the West
wants I feel like that puts them in a
really tough spot right because then
they're hearing
the Islamists taking their their beliefs
their belief system yeah then they have
they have to deal with the left that's
yep
you know usually ignoring them or or or
worse than ignoring them what what do
you think it's like for the fruit is
nominal do you've a better word I don't
like the word nominal yeah and so you
know you know nominal would suggest that
it's it's not a serious commit right
right right that's why just talk about
mainstream and the mainstream that
doesn't mean they're liberal or
left-wing or right-wing it just means
that the ordinary everyday person away
anywhere else would have a faith okay so
for therefore the mainstream Muslim not
someone like you who's out there
yeah very outspoken by the fringe I make
no you know I don't deny that by the way
my views are not representative I don't
claim to be a representative of Muslims
I don't claim to speak on the are on
behalf of Islam and I'm not devout and
my liberalism and my outspoken liberal
views and my Universal liberalism and
call for humanism and all of that it is
a currently it is not a mainstream
popular voice from within Muslim
communities but then there wouldn't be a
need for change if it was right and
ironically your calls for liberalism
which I want to get into because I've
heard you talk about classical
liberalism as clear as anyone else that
I've heard unfortunately that it doesn't
seem to be taking root too much either
for you guys or for us United States but
for the mainstream Muslim what do you
think it's like for the average
mainstream Muslim right now that is just
caught between us because I think
there's so many for those of us that
care about this we're trying to extend a
hand we're then getting hit by the
people that want to slander and libel us
you just had to deal with something on
BBC which we'll talk about iPads and
stuff lately what do you think just for
that average person it's just trying to
live there I mean look this is my family
this is a community from which I was
into which I was born and from which I
come so I can speak from personal
experience I can speak from everything I
see in this community and I can tell you
the pressures are enormous that doesn't
justify some of the shortcomings because
of course with enormous pressures and
with enormous when the consequences are
so big certain things are unavoidable
certain positions must be taken and so
I'm critical of other not enough being
done and more needing to be done but I
can concede immediate
the pressures are enormous and those
pressures sometimes lead to responses
that must be contextualized when
understanding how enormous the pressures
are people effectively let's always
remember one thing we are talking of a
minority community and because it's a
minority community they're scared they
are scared that mainstream wider society
will turn against them and of course
Western civilization European history
especially has precedents for that
happening let's also not forget that
unlike in the United States where I'm
from in Europe in particular the UK but
generally our continent long may it live
United
except but we'll do this earlier from
now as that but but you know let's not
forget Europe in its recent history has
had a genocide against Muslims we've got
to remember that it is irresponsible of
us not to put that at the forefront of
our minds it's what partly radicalized
me when I was 16 1516 onwards I say
obviously radicalization is more than
just grievances it's also ideology but
grievances are a factor and the genocide
against Muslims in Bosnia which is
recognized by most right-minded people
as a genocide is is something that is
ever present in the minds of these
Muslims so keep in mind those pressures
if they were if there had been you talk
about African Americans in the United
States that's the only analogous thing
to bring with the history of slavery
here that we are in a sense the African
Americans of Europe it's the Muslims and
there has been a genocide against us now
in that context to say that they are
worried about backlash because currently
factually there isn't anything on the
scale of attacks against Muslims as
there have been by jihadist against
everybody else but you can't ignore that
history and you can't say they're not
rightly worried about a backlash and so
those immense pressures are there it
doesn't justify it doesn't excuse some
of the lack of outspoken and open and
candid and an honest conversation that I
think needs needs to be had but it does
mean that we've just got when we when we
flesh pressure them for that we're just
going to recognize some of the pressures
that are on them yeah so how are you
able to gauge the the success or the
nuts
success of what you guys are doing not
from within the Muslim community so like
you know from the world that we live in
and I think from from the real liberals
I think there's an incredible amount of
traction if I if you know I tweeted out
that you're coming on today ton of
people we're excited about it but what
about gauging the success that you're
having within the Muslim community how
do you figure out if they're making them
are well so when I um there's lots of
people I didn't really know that I bet
on your show because the early days oh
um but when I was first on your show and
you know we did it over Skype as I was
on the East Coast at the time yeah I
think was just after my conversation
with sam harris islam in the future of
tolerance and back then just to answer
your question as to how the debate
shifted within the muslim community
because of that conversation with sam
harris somebody who had been a member of
Al Muhajiroun and then left them about
ten years ago and was on his own
evolution and journey but was still
antique William ante my organization and
my efforts to counter Islamist extremism
and Muslim fundamentalism together and
his name's Adam Dean he read the book
just out of curiosity my last
conversation with him had been hostile
he had pretty much told me that
everything I was doing was rubbish but
he read it out of curiosity and that's
credit to him because he had a curious
mind um had been on a trajectory his
former group was an offshoot of my
former group his birthday idea split and
mahadji room was a faction that emerged
from it led by Omer Buckley Mohammed
founded by him who had been the leader
of his battalion in the UK that group
when Tom's effectively become Isis in
Britain hmm 10 years 15 years after its
split from his battalion it went on its
own journey and junk Chaudhary the
infamous anjaan Chandra was its UK
leader on my bucket is currently in
prison in Lebanon Anjem Choudary is
currently in prison in Britain for
swearing allegiance to Isis on the
Buckley's son died fighting for Isis in
Syria that's the group Adam before the
group became proscribed because it also
had been on a journey from being an
offshoot of his birth hers had become a
fully-fledged
Jolley's group before it became
isis-affiliated Adam left them but still
hadn't yet clarified his
on this he read my dialogue with Sam and
that same guy now is the UK director of
Quilliam yeah and that's an example of
some of the change in the shift that's
happened in this conversation he brings
with him a constituency and I say that
word deliberately because of course
there's still much more to do with in
Muslim communities but he carried with
him a constituency from within the
Muslim community that had previously
been hostile to my work add to that that
we now have to two theologians at
Quilliam of the highest caliber
doctorate sam hasn't had already been
involved involved but he was he was in
those days the only one he was a you
know it was a strange thing it was
there's only one theologian that was
backing us now you've got those who now
full time at Quilliam Eve also as well
as Adam dr. Osama Hassan you've got
Salah and sorry who's an Egyptian
graduate of the university of al-azhar
which is the former sunni school of
theology in the world he was the Imam of
the main mosque in London and just just
I want your viewers to register for a
moment what this means Regents Park
mosque in central London is the main
mosque it's the one with a golden dome
it's a purpose-built mosque the former
Imam of that main British mosque the
most famous mosque in the UK is working
full-time at William and that was again
after my dialogue with Sam
there has been change and I think
there's a lot more to do we mustn't rest
on our laurels there's a lot more to do
but there has been movement and people
are saying what you know when is this
reform going to come is that come on
guys the hundred years or whatever 30
years were way yeah this thing doesn't
happen overnight by definition we're
engaged in a generational struggle does
that show you that the most important
thing that perhaps you've done is just
by being yourself that by you starting
this you've given cover in a way for
some of these other people to start
doing it and subsequently they will
start giving giving cover for other
young people - yeah this is the point
I've never claimed that I'm the one
who's going to do the theology right
yeah I've come from the tradition I've
studied the theology I memorized half
the Quran we can get to this when
talking about the Southern Poverty Law
Center yeah I agree but you know I come
from the tradition I've served time in
jail for my convictions in my religion
I have studied all of the theology and
learnt classical Arabic to do so I've
given my time if you like but I'm not
developed I'm not a religious Muslim I'm
not going to put myself out there
because that would be hypocrisy I could
have pretended I was you know but I
never claimed I was my only role was to
throw up on that conversation if it
stands true that the way forward is to
separate Islam from politics then you're
going to need separate voices you're
going to need Muslims who are engaged in
politics as secular Muslims and you're
going to need religious leaders engaging
engaging in the religion to have the
same voice doing both it's part of the
problem yeah right so you need to
separate those voices so my only role
was to throw up on that conversation and
then you have people like dr. ossama
hassanein Dean Salaam sorry who are
devout Muslims who do fast and pray five
times a day to take that forward on the
on a theological side is that the odd
position that you've been put in is that
unfortunately the left in this case they
don't they're not giving the room for
people like you to exist in a weird way
because I think most it it correct me if
I'm wrong but I would argue that most of
the criticism of you comes from the left
you're gonna get you're gonna get me
started on the left now inside you go
there I don't want to do it I really
don't want to do with Alice I think
there's there's a lot more rich stuff we
can talk about and people know what we
think about it yeah but that that
abandonment by the left has has sort of
built strange bridges in another way
that maybe weren't there so I think
there's actual some positivity yeah I
mean the guy you're talking to has come
up through the anti racism movement
through which I joined his battalion but
which was still couched in
anti-colonialism cause Islamists you
know use that language a lot this is a
guy who fought running street battles
with neo-nazis at the age of 15 knife
fights I'm told those guys came up with
hammers and machetes right um a guy who
joined anti-nazi League which is an
offshoot of the Socialist Workers Party
who were protesting the neo-nazis on the
streets who joined their rallies and
this is a guy you know I was accepted
resume radicalized by the by the Bosnian
genocide right this is a guy I would
have thought that that you know I had a
I would have had a problem and faced
resistance from the right because that's
all I've ever
faced resistance from you know I've
grown up in the days before the murder
of Stephen Lawrence in the United
Kingdom which was a watershed moment for
race relations in the UK it led to the
Macpherson inquiry an official
government inquiry which led to the
Macpherson report which concluded
officially from the UK government's
official position was after that inquiry
that there was institutional racism in
the UK police forces and much has
changed since then that's what I came up
through right my stabbing attacks that I
had to face were a year before Stephen
Lawrence was a black British teenager
was murdered
on the streets of view of the UK and no
one was brought to justice for about 15
20 years because these guys were
connected with their friends and family
in the police and there was it was a
massive miscarriage of justice it I have
only ever witnessed hostility from the
right who I am
that I can't even change is the colour
of my skin right my cultural and and
religious heritage I'd never expected to
be attacked from the left and when it
came it felt and what it didn't just
feel it was treachery of the highest
order because these guys these are the
same guys who say talk about
appropriation they say we want people of
color to speak and don't explain to them
listen to their voices their authentic
experiences right you know along comes
somebody
yeah who is the textbook definition of
the kinds of authentic experiences that
they want you to listen to but because
my conclusions don't match what they
want me to say because I'm not parroting
their answers suddenly they have a bit
of a brain fry and they can't they can't
reconcile that so they say okay people
have can I've been subjected to racism
check war on terror victimizes Muslims
check guess what guys I served in prison
in the war on terror people get tortured
check witness torture in jail they say
they say we're profiling Muslims their
airports a check that's happened to me
I've had my DNA taken from me and they
the UK suspended the Miranda rights in
ports of entry and exit from the UK so
if you're silent in an airport like
Heathrow it's a criminal offense right
that was done to me I was interrogated
and cautioned that my silence is a
criminal offense my DNA was taken from
me
check I've been banned from entry into
the United States I had to fight to get
that ban lifted check right all of the
grievances the left talked about and
they say you've got to listen to these
victimized voices okay fine listen to my
voice then when I'm saying to you
there's a serious and real problem
within our communities theocrats have
hijacked the debate that cultural
relativism is betraying the minorities
within our communities who are the gay
Muslims the X Muslims the feminists
Muslims the liberal Muslims the
dissenting voices the minority sects and
I say listen to this it's a real problem
and because they only want me to talk
about colonialism and foreign policy
suddenly I turn into the enemy that's
treachery of the highest order
yeah I wonder I try not to impugn
people's intentions I really try not to
I try to believe that the people that
maybe our intellectual opponents I
believe they think they're doing good
for the most part there were some people
that I think are not doing good and I'd
like to mention a couple them to you but
I was at a vent that I did at a school
University of Austin I think a couple
weeks ago and a kid came up to me at the
end and I could see he was really
nervous young kid he was 18 or 19 and he
said to me you know I'm ex-muslim and
and I see he was about to cry and he
said you know you've helped me just
talking about these things and then he
said to me he said there's something
else that I want to tell you I'm like
you yeah and he couldn't quite say that
he was gay what he was trying to say me
and I didn't know what to do and I kind
of hugged him and he ended they were
tears in his eyes yeah I thought what
craziness we're dealing with like the
things that people say about you or say
about me or say about Sam or ion or
these people that are fighting so that
everyone will be treated equally they've
they've pinned people like this poor kid
into feeling like he's almost like a
betrayer by by coming to an event where
this is it when when that voice comes
along or when my voice comes along and
we check all the grievance boxes that
are left always talks about with people
of color but we don't parrot their
conclusions and yet even then the
attackers for it
it tells me that they were weaponizing
and using our grievances for their own
ideological dogma because the moment our
conclusions didn't match with their
dogma they then ended up attacking us
too so they're clearly not interested in
our grievances yeah otherwise they would
say okay no you know what as they always
say though
speak for that person of color let that
person of color speak for themselves and
don't judge their cultural experience
that's a valid experience that you have
to learn from that's what they say about
the african-american history here right
it's always about not appropriating
voices that are not theirs and yet all
of a sudden I know I'm labeled a native
informant or an Uncle Tom because my
voice doesn't match with the conclusions
they want to come to and that this guy
that you met it's happened to me so many
times I was the first British Muslim on
national television for BBC question
time as a political peril it's a
well-known panel debate and during the
time just before gay marriage equality
was legalized in the UK there was a
debate on this panel I was on it and we
had a DUP leader Ian Paisley jr. DUP is
currently famous because the
Conservative government in the UK is
considering an alliance with a DUP to
stay in power this is an anti-gay anti
all sorts of thing you know very altra
conservative socially party and an Ian
Paisley jr. was on my panel then and I
and I openly it's you can see the clip
on YouTube I said you're a bigot and
your views are bigoted and it was on gay
marriage the number of gamers limbs
writing to me saying we've never heard a
Muslim man defending us in this way on
on television and the emotional
responses I got it tells me the sheer
level of vulnerability and isolation
that they feel when surveyed I think 52%
of British Muslims said they would ban
homosexuality it's according to Trevor
Phillips ICM poll before that a Guardian
poll found that 0 % said that being gay
was morally justified yeah imagine how
it feels to be a gay Muslim and yet the
left doesn't activate this book they
were aggressively yeah that doesn't want
to acknowledge that there's a problem
within the community I'm glad you almost
made that big wave because I think it
illustrates a point we're doing this
live for an hour you just got off a
plane I think you missed your first
flight to get here you're doing
real-time tonight you're doing another
thing at 2:00 a.m. our time here you
have other things going on here there's
a chance you could slip and just
accidentally say the left there and then
you know or we know unfortunately
there's a certain subset of people that
are going to go I
you see yeah yeah my kids talking about
all of that yeah that danger I when you
were on Sam's podcast last time I think
you talked a little bit about a force
field that you sort of need to build
your shield that's right right uh these
are my stall was in uh Star Trek a
knowledge I got plenty of stuff for a
Luke Scott thats me at Target you can
take a picture in front of it they'll
don't be printed I was wondering it
doesn't look like that's me as Lou
Bega's
um but but that concept of if you just
screw up a word you know you're gonna be
under assault yeah this is kind of a new
thing right like and how much attention
should we pay it pay to that well I
think I think we've got a the Internet
has led to this right because it is
instant responses we've got to allow for
human error yeah what I think is what's
more important is the substance of what
somebody's saying and knowing what
they're trying to say based on their
historical record and so even if even if
now I'd said the left and hadn't said
they're aggressive left and have carried
on and hadn't corrected my sentence if
you know my work you know what I'm
referring to yeah right and so it's
important to put somebody's words in the
context of what they're saying the other
mistake people often make I've been
known to be engaged in dialogue not
running with Sam Harris but with other
ex-muslims prominent ex-muslims Lycaon
Hirsi Ali and people throw at me from
within the Muslim community but I on
said we're at war with Islam and Islam
must be destroyed and the other mistake
people make is they don't allow for
people's views to have evolved since
from when they're quoting them you could
bring stuff up from me in the year 2006
it's online right when I got fresh out
of prison I did a BBC heart talk
interview with Sarah Montague and I was
at a rally in London this so called out
could stay rally the very guy that
called me a preacher today I spoke at
his rally in 2006 but nowhere he has a
member of his battalion right and you
know it's before I left the group you
could bring this stuff up but everyone
knows not only have I changed since then
I'm actually now I'm you know very vocal
against that group so the other thing
we've got allow for isn't just human
error but also human evolution yeah you
know people move and mature and change
so don't quote me stuff from am ten
years ago when she's just written a book
just now called heretic in which she
says I'm going to start differentiating
between Islam and Islamism and
support muslin reformers doesn't it also
it shows sort of it's like a lack of
tolerance in a really strange way
because it's not just you're not
allowing someone to evolve
you're also pinning them on words yeah
that don't take the breath of their work
I mean you know I've now gotten to know
I had a little bit this is the most
lovely person on the face of the planet
and the idea that they're giving well we
got you on that one set and also you've
got to be able to disagree with somebody
and recognize their lovely human being
which is another I say let's make that
the third element but even if after you
allow for human error and you allow for
human evolution you've also got to allow
for humanity yeah you know just as a
human being you know we mentioned
earlier off it off off air and we can
come to him if you want but Douglas
Murray yeah you know the guy is a very
civil a very genteel when you meet him
one-on-one
very polite you know to a fault just in
the way he is you know the typical just
think of the typical Etonian English
mannerisms
this man has yeah you know for us in
America that's a lot of Downton Abbey
yeah the way we can get it is what it is
right the guy he belongs on the set of
Downton Abbey yeah as a side I first
cast eyes on my wife my now wife yeah in
that intelligence squared debate I did
against Teyana dumbest really and
Douglas and I were waiting in there in
the maritime hotel and back then we
weren't friends and we weren't on civil
terms we were being civil but we weren't
friends and so we're sitting at opposite
ends of the lobby I didn't I don't know
what he was thinking but I didn't want
to engage with the opponent right before
this debate and we're both waiting to be
received by a by the IQ squared
representative so they sent this car
pretty much like you did to bring me
here they sent this car and they sent
somebody to come and to receive us at
the maritime Hotel in New York and in
walks this tall beautiful model s
looking woman Rachel turns out to now my
wife I married her we both saw her at
the same time I'm secretly thinking
thank God Douglas yeah because he's a
really smooth operator alright and and
because he's gay you know there was no
competition and you know I imagine that
if he wasn't gay I probably would have
not been married in just by him being if
he had been straight this whole thing
could have just beard off he could have
gone in there boys
right so the point
making it human you got allow for human
error human evolution and humanity
Douglas Murray and I are on different
ends of the political spectrum he and I
will disagree on which way to vote I
didn't vote conservative in this general
election we just had another one yeah
sick of the years you'll have another
one better yes to do i voted but I
didn't vote conservative I voted Liberal
Democrat yeah I'm a liberal I stood for
Parliament as a Liberal Democrat Douglas
Murray is highly critical of my party
and the views and values it stands for
we're on different ends of the political
spectrum he is somebody who I imagine
votes conservative he often espouses the
views and and and of the Conservative
Party on on a number of issues but
you've got all hours I say for the
Humanities if we want the kind of
civilization and this is good concluding
point on this note if we want to allow
for the kind of civilization what are we
fighting against with Islamists and the
theocrats we're fighting against their
desire to shut down everything they
don't agree with you know and so in
return when we're fighting for our
civilizational values we our problem
with them is they want to shut down
everything they don't want they don't
agree with so how how it does it make
sense that we mimic that you know I'm
happy that there are right-wing or
left-wing views out there I want that to
remain this what is everything I'm
fighting for yeah you know I want
somebody to say magic I'm sorry but your
views on taxation and the National
Health Service are are mad yeah I'll be
like yeah good Anya carry on you know
because that's exactly what I'm fighting
for right and that's why for me and you
know it's different for everybody I have
found it easier to have sit downs with
conservatives or libertarians who are to
the right of me on certain things but
they're willing to say well we got to
live in the same society together where
a lot of the people on the Left seem if
you think differently about abortion or
certainly about Islam or a few of these
other things they imp you as a human
being and I think that's where the
disconnect is which is why someone like
you and I on and brigitte gabriel who's
been here we are anti muslim extremists
according to the southern
so when you woke up and saw that thing I
saw you did on Twitter
but I mean for all you do and and for
the human not much of the public person
but for the human what's that like well
it was a massive head in the hands
moment was thinking my god you know
they're based in Alabama by the way you
know so you've got these white eyes
these white non-muslim guys yeah and it
is relevant people say why are you
bringing identity because obviously I'm
against identity politics of course but
it is relevant because the point is
these are people who play the identity
politics game so by their own criteria
they're being hypocrites you know you've
got these white men sitting in sweet
Alabama deciding from up on high in
their ivory tower to devise lists and
label people in this way with no with no
taste for or real experience in the real
danger that that brings you know we talk
about lists we look at what happened in
Bangladesh and the jihadists listed
people that they called atheists Muslims
in reality they were liberal Muslims
ex-muslims secular Muslims a whole bunch
of humanist Muslims they heard you add
it or what atheist is all an infidel
right so they listed this and then one
by one those people started getting
assassinated yeah that's just the truth
of it it happened in Bangladesh it
happened with a on in the Netherlands
it's not just an Eastern phenomena it's
happening in Europe again fielder's was
was murdered and the list they stuck on
his body no no no no gurgler sorry sorry
I go oh my god yeah direction wow so
that well that's the importance of
that's the quote that our they all
connected without a human oh yeah I said
Theo van Gogh I do apologize to you back
ah do you guys just anybody see a lot of
articles inside him good yeah because
the team van Gogh was murdered yeah it's
all patch names and gets a variety of
Van Gogh home it wasn't be added and
they start they stabbed a list in his
body and ion was listed next yeah you
know that's what happens when you make
lists people because whether it's some
right-wing lists or left-wing place that
really think of the political horseshoe
theory if you go far left enough you end
up behaving exactly as the far right and
it's why we study Stalin and Hitler
together in history lessons in the
United Kingdom because whether you got a
fire left guy or a far-right guy this
guy had concentration camps this guy had
the Google
but it's effectively this guy murdered
all his opponents this guy murdered all
his opponents this guy said anyone who
challenges him is the enemy of the
people this guy said anyone who
challenges him is the enemy of the
people
and that's the political horse shake you
go far enough you end up with you and
you know what a horseshoe does if you
think about it's a powerful thing
because you know you start from here and
you go up and it Forks and it ends up at
the top now Starling and Hitler both
let's say they're both there but it's
interesting they're from a bomb because
to me that represents authoritarianism
and totalitarianism
and that's the issue here you know and
so and so we can't be consistently as
people on who are coming from the
liberal trajectory we can't have we
cannot morally complain about
McCarthyism if we're doing the same
thing on the liberal end of the
political spectrum and I and I
distinguish between the left and liberal
these days so we can get to that yes so
let's just jump into that quickly
because I did a video about three months
ago saying that the left is no longer
liberal so I've I have shifted in my
language a little bit the way I use I
because when I refer to the modern left
now yeah they are not liberal in the
classical liberal tradition know it's
funny when I titled it that video
quickly did a Google search because I
wanted to make sure we weren't going to
step on anything or people are gonna
confuse anything and I came up with one
of your clip I'd already done anything
you had done I think it may have
literally been the same and it was cool
the left is no longer liberate so am i
LBC shot yeah exactly so I so I watch
the clip and I've said you said
everything that I only about this why do
you so again so in a weird way it goes
against the differentiation that that
we're having to make now but they're on
regressive weather and left yeah because
we're both acknowledging there is a
difference yeah the left is no longer
liberal in today's sense of what the
left is I think is accurate yeah but
that doesn't mean it's all regressive
left okay right so how I look at it is
you've got the control left people ask
me because you know I had this other
phrase control left control left alt
right deliberate
so people are magically making some
money oh yeah they say yeah this is my
before the language see so people like
what is a control left yeah and I say
okay and they're saying are you now
replacing the word regressive left
because Dave Rubin kind of overused it
to the control no no no no guys the
regressive left is still a concept that
has its value in purpose and describes a
specific subset of the left the control
left to my mind
is the authoritarian left the regressive
left isn't the same as that and here's
an example of it to give again another I
go to these solid examples just to make
the point I don't to bring everything
back to Hitler and Stalin but but here
you look at starting it really does
drive the point home
Stalin wasn't a cultural relativist
right so in that sense he wasn't
regressive left but there is clearly an
authoritarianism in Stalin and that's
how you see the difference that what I
mean by the control left is the
totalitarian authoritarian approach
right uh Stalin wiped out religion in
Russia hated religion right you know
what he did to the Muslims in Chechnya
is well documented so you could be
somebody whose control left or not
regressive left and you could be
somebody who's regressive left and not
control left and so so it's correct
though to say that the modern left with
its leading voices today isn't liberal
in that it focuses on communalism over
individual autonomy it focuses on a
fence over free speech it focuses on a
blasphemy over heresy I'd say a modern
liberal today needs to be a heretic
needs to value free speech needs to
value individual rights and individual
autonomy over communalism and those are
key distinguishes for me today between
what are the leading voices on the left
and the leading voices who are liberals
still different from the right wing yeah
so are those traditions that you're
talking about classical liberal
traditions having nothing to do with
Islam right now do you think that those
ideas are taking root in Britain right
now well no I mean we're on the backfoot
what's taking root is the polarization
politics um the Liberals voice in the
way that I've just described it is being
hammered by all sides and is finding
itself increasingly isolated yeah do you
think it's shifting to the right because
what I said at least here and it's not
exactly the same is that because at
least in America right now there is a
little more of a tradition of
individualism on the right that I think
that the the people that are of the left
that want that believe in individualism
in classical liberalism they're
realizing there's virtually nothing left
there's just scorched earth over here
they see the way they're treated when
they have the alternate opinion
like that and I do sense there's a
shifting to the right I don't think
that's necessarily bad but I would
rather keep everybody I would have
advised around classical liberal I would
advise them pin your flag to the mast
and be the last man standing them out of
what it takes and not shift to the right
idea I don't think it's it's a in Brit I
can see opening here in Britain it's not
happening what's happening is they're
shifting to the left they gave nothing
they're giving up and they're saying
okay say this last election okay between
Corbin and Teresa main are Corbin is the
left-wing populist yeah leader of the
Labour Party currently hot he and his
momentum movement i jacked the Labour
Party from within and he's now kind of
the you think of outright the populist
left version of it is Jeremy Corbyn
right
and people are now saying okay between
Theresa May and her potential alliance
with the DUP and the disastrous way in
which she handled this fire tragedy
which has had was horrible the grand mal
fire tragedy absolute eighty people lost
their lives and and it was all
vulnerable people and could have been
and would have been and that should have
been avoided if the Conservative
government implemented some
recommendations that they were already
given and that the Housing Minister of
that government pledged Parliament to
implement and didn't write and people
are saying okay between these guys who
don't care for vulnerable communities
and and this guy who says he does care
there's no point voting Liberal Democrat
we're going to vote Corbin so that is
interesting so we really are having an
opposite split here but it's still it's
the same thing though it's populism and
it's authoritarian tendencies going this
way or that way and so you look at the
political horseshoe actually it's not
that different when you're at the top
there what we need to try and do is keep
people in their respective political
positions because we don't want I often
say unity and religion is theocracy
unity in politics is fascism right we
don't want unity in politics we don't
want to all say the same thing people
say come on let's agree to get along and
ignore our differences those differences
are a good thing right because unity in
politics is fascism it's what more
Shalini brought so we've got a somehow
devised a way of pinning our flag to the
Masters liberals while also defending
the left and right wing positions and
allowing them to be left and right wing
our enemy is when you're at the top of
that wall shoots the authoritarianism
and the populism that's the danger and
unfortunately currently we're you know
on a bit of a back foot with that battle
yeah well I'll stay in that spot with
you as long as it takes and hopefully
that's why I talked about philosophies
here more than just what happened
yesterday or what a Trump tweet because
I want people to understand the basic
philosophies so that they can come to
some conclusions instead of everyone's
just lost in the 24-hour news cycle and
that just that just leads to more
hysteria the polls are saying today by
the way if there was an election again
in Britain because tourism a lost her
majority and did abysmal poorly and is
turning out to be a very poor Prime
Minister Jeremy Corbyn would win do you
think her worst moment Theresa May his
worst mum was just a couple days before
the election when she said something to
the effect of will change human rights
laws if that will keep us safe did you
catch that I did what I'm slightly
butchering yeah and I responded to it
she gave four points to respond to the
horrific London Bridge terror attacks
you know of course I'm speaking to you
after four months of as many so four
attacks in as many months in the UK we
have four terrorist attacks in four
months and the grenfell fire tragedy
which was which also shocked the nation
it's it's difficult for me to explain
how shook the nation was after that fire
tragedy it was a burning Inferno and it
was just everything that could have gone
wrong went wrong yeah and people were
like is this still happening in 2017 so
so she after the long Tereza made the
Prime Minister after the London Bridge
terror attack came out with a four point
strategy and one of them touched on
human rights and she's always been a bit
state heavy always preferred arrest what
I call law and war over the civil
society debate she's been like that
since she's been in the home home office
as Home Secretary and in fact she and I
and her Department sounds bigger than it
is but she had the Department on just
one voice but we were at loggerheads
over this and eventually David Cameron
when he was Prime Minister picked my
approach over hers and she's never
forgiven me for that in her department
at her key people her key voices have
never forgiven Quilliam and my voice for
for Cameron siding with us over that
debate but then of course she became
Prime Minister yeah and was able to do
whatever she wanted to do and her two
advisers Nick Timothy and Fiona
who were her Chiefs of Staff when with
her from the Home Office to Downing
Street and again they remember that spat
and a conflict and David Cameron siding
with us on this
so they also carried that with them to
Downing Street they've obviously since
resigned they've had to since the
general election performance but but
Theresa May has always had a preference
for just where where she can't
understand the intellectual debate
Bannock you know do this do that
legislation regulate the internet is
only one right as if you're going to be
able to do that from the United Kingdom
is that hard I think that's hard for a
certain amount of people to understand
that someone with this much power and
again it's why I talk about the
philosophies where she said what do you
remember what the exact line was will
change those human rights laws or
something something similar yes
sometimes she said we were we will we
will regulate make the UK the world's
leader in regulating the Internet right
is a recipe for making the UK the
farthest behind in being at on the
Internet what will the rest of our
whanau here a director this is this most
people hear that I think it's a problem
yeah but but she said it didn't see
there didn't seem to be any caution in
her voice they don't see any hesitancy
now I get it a terrorist attack happens
you want to appear strong you want to
appear like you're gonna stop the next
one or whatever it is but it seems to me
that if you're a thinking person maybe
this is exactly what your point is have
people heard that and they go that is
dangerous that's dangerous state power
so now even though we don't like Corbin
we're going that way and maybe that's
why well well after those London Bridge
attacks there were certain voices that
came forward who are traditionally over
conservative so military and police
forces traditionally the you know it's
it's they're associated with voting
consider military for example so there's
a Colonel Kemp who came out and said we
need Britain to open up its own
Guantanamo Bay and introduce internment
this is a respected military figure
saying it to the press after the London
Bridge attacks and so the problem of
course is that like I said earlier if
the very thing we hate with the
jihadists and Islamist ideologues from
which they emanate are is that they want
to undermine our human rights if we
recognize that what they're fighting us
for is because of our free democratic
secular open pluralist
society's right if that's what they hate
and why they're fighting us and if the
right wing is saying it's not about
grievances Dave it's not about you know
racism foreign policy it's about
ideology Dave it's not about grievances
that's what the right wing say okay fine
let's take your argument if it is about
ideology if it's true
working with your working assumption
that jihadists hate us because of our
freedom freedom and democracy then why
would you destroy rights very same
values yourself with your own hands
yeah which i think is partly I mean I
think that's a bigger part of the plan
than we have been given a license has
told us that right they're basically
saying we'll just this is the long war
and we're just going to let you guys do
destroy yourselves they're spelling out
for us that we're going to attack you in
these marauding Street attacks in this
randomized way we're just going to carry
on mowing your pedestrians down on your
streets until you people rise up and
start attacking Muslims too because then
there's a civil war and those Muslims
are going to come and fight under our
jihadist brigades to defend themselves
that's exactly what they want anyone
anyone calling for a civil war style
reaction to these terrorist attacks
doesn't truly understand their military
strategy and you can't defeat a military
strategy unless you understand what it
is and do everything to subvert it not
to reinforce it so I want to shift a
little bit to something that I think is
an actual really positive development
because we're talking about some sort of
political developments that don't sound
great about it there's a lot of bad
stuff here but one of the things that
I've been seeing lately is that there
are now public splits within the Muslim
community so there's the X Muslims
versus the I will no longer say nominal
Muslim the men stream Muslim versus
people that are slightly more religious
and there's a lot of infighting public
infighting I mean on Twitter and
whatever else I view that as a positive
thing absolutely because this is showing
wow people are standing up for what they
believe in you've got atheist Muslims
like our friend Ali yeah you've got you
know yaz Muhammad who is here oh I think
is an amazing ex Muslim you have people
that are trying to reform from the
inside like yourself and and what you
guys are doing Quilliam this shows now
on their ruling of the debate yeah yeah
so I think certain people look at it and
they go they're all fighting this is
going to just destroy it I think it
would reverse it spot-on and back to
what I said earlier
unity in politics is fascism unity in
religion is theocracy what we if we
achieve what we want to achieve
assuming you're with me on this Dave I
so far away now to believe that's a
terrible sin again did they catch oh
this is why we're name is just accused
me of dropping a bomb guys profiling
them no if we if we achieve what we want
to achieve and that is letting a
thousand flowers bloom the political
pluralism that we say is the is the you
know the essence of our civilization
then you will have this debate and it's
and it must long may remain you know it
has to be there um I want to see the
right-wing Muslims and the left-wing
Muslims and the X Muslims and the
liberal reforming was I want to see them
all debating and and disagreeing at in a
civil way of course because let's not
forget where this began and your viewers
maybe even yourself may not remember
it's been nine years since we set
Quilliam up nine years ago in London I
gave a talk a public talk before setting
Quinn him up to the talk probably ten
years ago just after I left his
battalion and the room was packed full
of Muslims because back then a lot of
these limits still had time for me I
haven't yet set quit him up and I just
left his whatever it was this guy gonna
say next and I in that talk in couching
it in religious language said
effectively we must be we must have a
way to arrive at secularism it was the
most controversial thing the video is
still online it was called the city
circle it's a ten year old YouTube
videos in like seven passes before
people started doing flashy edits or
videos right you know it's like a 20
minute segment in seven parts this is
awful too ghetto but he's going to work
no one's gonna but you know people were
outraged
Majid Nawaz is suggesting that we need
to begin somehow developing a secular
conversation within Islam the debate has
moved on so much and the reason I bring
this up is because ten years ago in
discourse within British Muslim
communities there wasn't that pluralism
of voices there was one voice and it was
the Islamist voice and that's theocracy
to have unity and politics is fascism to
have unity in religion is theocracy and
so the fab
all these this plethora of voices now
exists it's fantastic and and and that's
why I don't have a problem say I'm so
happy
there's over D jasser there's on the
Republican side of American politics as
a reforming Muslim I'm so happy that
there are even reformed Muslims who say
no we back Trump like Ostrow normani and
I'm so happy that there are others like
myself and a Liam rizvi who are saying
no we're liberals and we're not going to
vote Republican we're not going to back
Trump even doesn't that really show that
you stand for your principles because
it's the reverse of what they've been
doing to you you are fully admitting
these people who I disagree with deeply
politically on either side of this I'm
happy that they're out there doing it
but it preserves our civilization
everything we love and hold dear to is
political pluralism secularism democracy
and so you know we have to have those
voices and the fact that think about the
fact that there are Muslims saying we
back Trump and their Muslim saying we
back Republicans and Muslims saying we
back Obama or Hillary what that does is
either Islamist and remember that's what
we're all in this for is to try and push
back against the biggest threat to world
global security today's jihadist
terrorism the Islamist ideologue will
say no you're only allowed one voice in
politics and that's the theocratic voice
so the mere existence of these
pluralistic voices is a blow a severe
blow to the Islamist ideological project
it's why I'm so happy yeah any blow to
the Islamist ideological project is
progress yeah it's funny you know I see
there's there's real like sense of joy
within you which I know we all anyone
that stakes themselves out in any place
and you mentioned the force fields that
you were talking about yeah like there's
a certain cost yeah I sent at the moment
that you're on sort of a nice run at the
moment is it just not a total person
only because of how I'm coming across to
you yeah no I I couldn't do this if I
didn't really believe in it and and
passionately care for it and as a result
enjoy progress when I see it
but talking about good runs and cause
something look I I am on my emotional
personal toll that it's taken on me it's
still there very heavy and you know I
don't know why and this is probably for
psychologists to work out but no it's a
seriously heavy emotional to I have a a
16 year old boy
who haven't seen for a long time and I
wish I could see him again I wish I
could hold him he because I've just had
a five month old baby boy so I have two
boys and you know I want him to know his
brother but you know when I left his
battalion my wife left me and she raised
that boy and it's a terribly difficult
thing to be estranged from your own
flesh and blood after having been in
prison for five years and then why
brother as well disagrees with
everything I stand for him and he has
children and you know it's a difficult
thing and the only thing that gets you
through this is you've got to believe in
what you're doing you've got to believe
in in the fact that it's doing some some
good if people will judge that as to
whether it is doing good or not but know
it and what gets me through is that I
believe in what I'm doing if I if I if I
had even you know if I didn't believe I
wasn't as passionate then that other
stuff would have really weighed me
weight on me by now and I don't know
where I'd be
ya know I mean I say that if I've
learned one thing it's as an interview
it's there are moments when I can find
that somebody doesn't really believe
what they're saying right I see no
wavering in you and it's inspiring
actually it's the only thing we should
be certain about by the way is that
nothing is certain is it yeah that's
important value because people's comment
I'm convinced 100% of my position as men
he shouldn't be the only thing you
should be convinced of is everyone has a
position and we've got to preserve that
I think my position is right talk about
liberalism I think it's the best
political philosophy to arrive at but I
could be wrong yeah well you're gonna
see bill Martinez says all the time
it's okay every now and again to say I
don't know yeah and yet somehow in the
in the public discourse unless so let's
shift a little bit to two people that
it's there's a little neither here nor
there with both of them on this issue I
think so Piers Morgan first real quick
that you saw the video I'm sure from BBC
was a BBC Morning Show with Tommy yeah
we yeah yeah yeah yeah Robinson yeah but
I want to mention I saw I want to
mention piers first because piers seems
to be taking sort of every position on
this where there are times where I offer
him a public he was on real time and
trying to talk about this honestly and a
little bit of the ideas and pimple thing
and making the distinction and you know
I
forget who was that basically told him
to go [ __ ] himself and I was it wasn't
Larry Wilmore a blanket I saw that it
was ah yeah yeah it wasn't Larry mom or
somebody else but um I offered him a
full throttle defense you know like he's
trying here and even though I disagree
with this guy on a zillion he's trying
her then this thing happens on BBC more
it's confusion I was on Pierce's sure
before that and he wouldn't even let me
speak because of how much he was
agreeing with me yeah on that on you
know on there there's a problem we need
to do something about it right so we're
Tommy he wasn't letting him speak
because how much he disagreed with him
right with me he wasn't letting me speak
buzzer how much he agreed with what I'll
say right so this is more about the
psychological condition is it can work
yeah there's a completely secure usually
understandably so there's a confusion
among people who are just entering this
debate now you know somebody who spent
my entire life in this debate yeah I've
got to give a bit of leeway I so I'm
you're referring to the now-infamous
interview between Piers Morgan and Tommy
Robinson on Pierce's morning show in
yeah - just a couple days ago yeah
and it's online people could catch it
and it's kind of if you haven't already
watched it then your were you doing
watching the debut joke so everyone who
write you need to know yeah yeah it was
yeah it was almost uh it was a low-grade
yeah Sam verse athletic yeah it was one
of those moments you know and look Tommy
has his weaknesses yeah we don't get to
hear we're getting that's why I want to
do Peters do piers first um I tweeted
after this and I said with respect with
the utmost respect and appreciation that
mainstream journalists are worried about
anti-muslim bigotry rightly so we just
had the Finsbury Park mosque terror
attack Muslims were mowed down on the
streets in exactly the same way that
Isis jihadists are doing to non-muslims
despicable nothing can ever justify it
and if we talk about if we talk about
how Islamists we use foreign policy
grievances to justify jihadist terrorism
the same thing happened here people
started saying well come on you know
what did you expect Muslims have been
killing us but now you've just mowed
down innocent people that had nothing to
do even if they were that was an Islamic
mosque which it was well they aren't the
ones who murdered all those people on
the streets
you can't just murder innocent people
even
that very night they had been preaching
horrible things you can't do UConn the
snow you know I don't know the fact we
have to look at the times where I think
you can't murder innocent people as a
cell yes I just firmly utter on your
show you know like people were
controversial you never any card Dave
you can't murder in the severe we
understand right you're right okay you
still agree me I'm so okay so these are
you taking it so yes right so Pierce was
rightly outraged because people were
justifying the attack on social media
right
the problem with Pierce is that in that
interview as a problem with Pierce in
the interview the problem with Pierce
was that he was rightly outraged and I
thanked him in my tweet said I thank
mainstream journalist for genuinely
caring about anti-muslim bigotry as I
said we can't ignore the fact that we've
had a genocide against Muslims in Europe
yet so people are right when they say
but majid jihadist terrorism and
anti-muslim bigotry have nowhere near
each other on the scale that's true
Jadus terrorism is up there anti-muslim
bigotry is the fastest rising according
to the UK government stats by the way
he's not me making it up right a third
of all national referrals to the prevent
strategy which is the anti extremism
strategy the government has in place are
from far-right anti Muslim extremists
referrals most are still from jihadist
referrals but but this is they are the
fastest-rising the anti-muslim ones are
the fastest-rising referrals even if
they're not up there yet with a jihadist
and you put that into context of that
fact that Europe has a history of
institutionalizing on the state scale
genocide against minorities whether it's
a Holocaust or the Bosnia genocide you
can't understate the dangers of an ass
needing to be wary of this fast-rising
problem you know so in that sense Pierce
yeah thank you Pierce for being worried
about this that's what he was trying to
do and that's why I use the word
confusion right the road to hell is
paved with good intentions because you
don't do that you don't want to do that
defect what do what defend Muslims from
anti-muslim bigotry right right and why
is that important with everything we
just said right now you don't want to do
that by reinforcing blasphemy codes so
the moment for me that was a low point
in that interview is that Tommy's
holding up a copy of the Koran and
Pierce is saying put that book down and
show respect yeah now that in other
words Pierce is saying don't blaspheme
because legally and morally there's
nothing wrong with holding a book
been here like that unless you're going
to say you're being blasphemous and that
was for me a low point that we cannot to
challenge anti-muslim bigotry
we cannot reinforce blasphemy codes
because then what we're doing is
reinforcing another form of bigotry
which is the Islamists going around
murdering blasphemers in our own
communities you know so there's got to
be a way to do it and that's my mantra
this is the way to our answer to the
problem here right now
yeah no idea is above scrutiny and no
person is beneath dignity
so what peers should have done is let
Tommy criticize the Quran he's got every
right to criticize the crime yeah just
I've got every right to criticize
Shakespeare it's a book right he's got
every right in a free and open society
to say what he likes about this book is
holding up and and for peers to say show
some respect is exactly there a rhetoric
that led to the Charlie Hebdo massacre
yeah it would be careful it also showed
to me you know the phrase that bill uses
a lot that a bunch of us have sort of
used as well which is the soft bigotry
of low expectations yeah that Piers was
trying to be so moral and so virtuous
but he was defending a set of ideas that
would not do good things to him that
doesn't of course that doesn't mean all
the people who believe in it I mean
we've been through all this before but
but I think that's a good transition to
Tommy because you've had a bit of a
history with Tommy yeah I've had Tommy
on the show and and part of the reason I
had him on the show was because he was
after I had you on at that time you guys
probably just was it before off fly out
to me video it was after yeah so he had
so I think you guys were a little more a
little more in lockstep right so you so
basically you helped him leave the EDL
you you thought that there was some
fertile ground there to work together on
some things listen when I when I see
Tommy and I'm not I'm not in Britain but
what I can see from social media things
I think basically he doesn't strike me
as a bigot and I think he's basically
trying he's seen his society change in
the way he doesn't like and he's trying
excuse me he's trying to fight for
something now I may be missing something
and and what he did by showing up at
your office and putting it on video
which creates a security situation all
that now that's I'm offering no defense
of that whatsoever
that being said where where are you guys
at he called in before that incident
which you know I wish you hadn't done
because you know the point is I've got
bigger fish to fry right so you know to
come in there are people who have called
in live on my radio show and said I had
plans to assassinate you
as a jihadist and you know thank you
because I've changed it's been two years
but come on imagine how that feel I'm on
a live radio show recording and say we
we were actually we he said I can make
bombs and we had plans to kill you
and he named Malala yousufzai and me and
ayaan Hirsi Ali but we're the two in
Britain right and this is a vibe from
the UK in that climate where people are
being murdered on our streets for saying
less than what I say for Tommy to come
into it into our Quilliam HQ with a
camera exposing our office to the world
because it was a Sikh we didn't announce
to anyone where our office was you know
I just wish he hadn't done that because
there was no need I've got bigger fish
to fry there was no need to turn your
guns on if you're looking for allies
from within the Muslim community to
challenge Islamism know better and I've
been quit him what'd you find there was
no need to turn your guns on us before
that incident according to my radio show
it was again a surprise call like the
assassination while that's right you
never know what you're gonna get yeah
it's live LBC Colin isn't it so you know
you don't know what you're gonna get so
he called him and he used a different
name and he got through and he said and
and you know I don't know why I don't
filter the calls my producers do you
know people that work in radio know how
these things won't get through to the
producers they filter the cause and give
you the best ones yeah because lots of
people are calling in and I don't know
if people know the game so they'll say
something else to this right exactly and
that is a producer job to make sure that
you know somebody's going to break the
law for example on live radio yeah there
are legal responsibilities involved so
he got through in the end and I gave him
a lot of time to speak and if you listen
to that you ankh Williams YouTube
account we uploaded the conversation and
if you listen to that conversation in
that conversation I conceded much of the
substance of what Tommy was saying to me
about it was just after the attacks
which attacks were they the westminster
attack khalid Massoud who attacked in
Westminster before the Manchester attack
and before the London Bridge attack and
before the Finsbury Park mosque attack
it was the first of those four even
as you see that it's like it's really
getting harder to remember these and
that's just in four months right so it
was after the first one of those four
attacks I've just listed the Westminster
attack Khalid Masood jihadist former
associate of Al Muhajiroun and I
understand Tommy's anger because he's
from Luton where Al Muhajiroun
Bay made the base of their activity you
know and ruined his hometown as a result
so he called in and he said everything
I've been saying about the Luton mosque
is correct they advertised this guy as
their spokesperson and all of that I've
not only said yet you're right Tommy
100% said if politicians are listening
right now on this point Tommy is correct
I said that on my show and then where I
disagree with him and I said Tommy after
the Westminster attack you were standing
outside Westminster on one of your live
poker and you were saying Muslims have
been attacking us for 1400 years and
that's where I'm saying look Tommy
you've got it just you know Muslims have
been attacking you for 1400 years my
grandfather fought with the British Army
you know in World War two you got to
just be a bit there are people that died
Muslims died in World War two fighting
for Britain against Hitler so saying
Muslims have been fighting us for 1400
years is feeding into that clash of
civilizations civil war rhetoric that
that the jihadists want to create you
know so I just said on the thing of your
viewers can watch that clip you know so
we'll link to it down below and uh and I
said Tommy just that rhetoric I said I I
put my credibility on the line within my
own Muslim communities to help you leave
the EDL because I believe that humans
can change and I changed and I want
others to change and I've never claimed
to have D radicalized Tommy a lot of
like even when the Muslim side out say
magic claim to deride and I said look at
him now is that I never made that claim
what we said was we rendered the EDL
leaderless which was a good thing and
Tommy said it was a good thing because
they've been infiltrated by neo-nazis
which is the reason he said he left them
right what I wish had done a bit more of
is people often say Majid you left HT
and people have given you a second
chance he's left video why can't he have
a second chance and what I wish he'd
done a bit more of and I hope he still
does because he's got a lot of good to
contribute right I left HT and turned my
guns on my former ideology the reason I
left was that
Islamism I believed had had come to
represent the very beast that I wanted
to fight when I first joined them raised
is in discrimination so I realize
Islamism is all of those things so I
turned my guns back on Islam ISM and
ever since leaving that group have been
fighting the very reason I left his body
area right Tommy said he left the EDL
because it'd been infiltrated by
neo-nazis so even he acknowledges
there's a problem otherwise it wouldn't
left the EDL which was his own group
yeah so I wish he'd done a bit more to
turn his guns on that neon autism you
know and that's where he's gonna watch
this and I hope I hope he does that a
bit more of that yeah but on the piers
thing and he's probably seen my tweet
you know saying this piers was wrong to
tell him to put the Quran down and show
show some respect and shout to him in
that way everybody has the right I'm
lifting a cup right now you've got the
right to lift a book I mean come on guys
you know you're holding a book in the
area how is that even even if one were
to believe in blasphemy guys how's that
even less honest right so I'm up in the
air is that modern-day blasphemy now
yeah imagine see and that's the irony
that I think in some ways people like
piers in this specific instance they
strengthen the bad side more than
certainly more than Tommy well in that
moment because because that because
Tommy's sitting there going do you know
about what's in here and I'm read it and
it's obvious that piers hasn't and then
the average person that's watching that
I'm not talking not even the mainstream
Muslim just an average person anywhere
they were watching that goes it's pretty
clear who doesn't know what's going on
in that book yeah it's clearly here who
does yeah and that's why you know this
conversation has just been leveled in so
many years and that's the confusion and
you know we are all of us fumbling and
stumbling and mumbling our way through
this debate right all of us yeah and
that's why I said Lao room for human
error human evolution and humanity on a
human level meaning humans 101 are human
beings and treat them still with respect
even if you discount the human error and
the human evolution you still disagree
with somebody there's still a human
being
and those three humans right just allow
that to happen because we're stumbling
and mumbling and fumbling our way
through this conversation mistakes will
be made
it's new to all of us it's new it's a
new conversation we're used to dealing
with communism in the West we're used to
dealing fascism and Nazism this is the
first time we're dealing with this one
so mistakes will be made people are
confused they don't want to do the wrong
thing that although they wanted what's
the right thing to do they don't know
so Pierce made a mistake Tommy's made
mistakes I've made mistakes you know and
all of us if you even recognize that
we've got to get through this together
that's what we've got to do then we will
each advise and correct each other on
the way and as I said earlier Tommy can
stay on the right wing all he wants I'm
not there and I won't vote for that but
you can stay on the right wing all he
wants there's room for improvement
Pearce used to edit one of the left wing
tabloids in the UK the mirror right I
don't know where he's these days better
you can stay another day
you can stay wherever he is but his room
again for improvement and as there is
with me you know yeah
well as they really with this me as well
clearly your excuse me probably a bomb
here inside that I mean yes well first
off I really want to thank you for doing
this we've already gone over an hour and
you're doing really outside yeah well I
mean I could go yeah I mean we can keep
going for a little bit yeah uh I mean if
it depends I don't want to like you know
what I don't ruin your shot oh yeah
rumor I mean this is this is it this is
what I do this is a pure joy so you know
what I'll ask you one other thing and
I'll let you give it a nice closing
statement so along with that we're all
fumbling through this a new voices keep
coming in oh yeah you know trying to
figure we talked about this briefly
right before we sat down trying to
figure out who we can trust
and something so imam tweety tweety
don't he d this is enough well is he now
you being racist I win here yeah so he
is sort of burst onto the scene he's an
Australian Imam he's now verified on
Twitter he went on my friend lale Josh's
podcast he's done a bunch of other
things and there seems to be a feeling
right now that this this is the hot new
guy to come and reform Islam and talk
about it from the inside and all this
value now I was with our friend faisal
site on Matar last night and i said a
lot of people want him champion faisal
Mathari the champ i love it i just adore
so but i was on we need to hear more of
those voices by the way I would say this
I'm biased and let me put my cards on
the table yeah liberal ex-muslims ali
rizvi faisal Mathare liberal ex-muslims
because there are lots of different
types of X Muslims and so I'm saying my
bias is liberalism the liberal X Muslim
voices you know we need to champion them
more yeah absolutely and I will always
offer the Messiah
but I said to face a last night I said
you know a lot of people want me to have
him on the show but he's so new to this
and I cannot sit here I will not pretend
looking used directly in the Iowa I
pretend that I know every verse of the
Koran every in and out of every
different set and all those things that
for me to have that conversation
responsibly with someone who just got on
the scene I don't know that I'm quite
able to do it properly so Faizal has
already offered if the three of us could
do it maybe so maybe we'll do it that
way but I but on the more broad sense ad
you do you know anything about him book
but be but what about people that just
sort of burst on yeah so I was able to
speak to you about Pierce and Tommy and
because I met them spoken to them I know
them yeah I don't know him am taki D I
never met him I'd never heard of him
until about somebody people obviously
lots of people ask me about I've never
heard of him until about a month ago so
I can't speak about someone I don't know
who I've never met who I've never even
discussed with letter in real life even
on social media I've never exchanged a
word with him yeah and so what I can say
though not knowing this person and not
wanting to put words and attribute in
you know motivations and intentions to
somebody who I genuinely don't know
anything about what I can speak about is
on a broader level in answering your
question how a sign of the success of
some of what we're doing and the need
for a reformed discourse within Muslim
communities and Aunty Islamist discourse
and I want to get to that by the or the
difference between reformers the
difference between reforming Islam
challenging Islamism Muslim apologetics
there's a bit of a confusion I'll get oh
but I'm what I can say is a sign of the
success of this work is that there will
be new voices coming along whether
they're jumping on the bandwagon or not
we don't know I don't know this guy so I
can't comment there I assume the best of
intentions I hope for any fellow human
being but the sign of the success of
this work is that there will be new
voices coming on so that's a positive
first let's let's Network Bank that
right that's in the bank that look new
voices people wanting to talk about this
subject can only be a good thing or
we'll all fumble and mumble and stumble
our way through it together
as we just agreed yeah right secondly I
would say another thing a word of
caution I've been doing
long enough now we all know each other
and you know with unknown entities that
emerge and again let's not personalize
it with amount of behavior at any one
that emerges in the future even we've
just got to be going to remember and I'm
going to give you two examples from two
different sects from within the Sun
Sunni and the Shia Islamic sects just so
we understand that you know it's it's
often complicated to know where
somebody's coming from right within the
Sunni Islamic denomination there is a
community within South Asia called the
Barelvis the barelli's are a very ultra
conservative socially ultra conservative
strictly religious Sufi sect within the
Sunni denomination of Islam in South
Asia in particular that's where they are
and they are the default majority in
countries like Pakistan the default
village Islam will be better the Islam
right now these guys hate these limits I
speak a bit about this in my dialogue
with Sam Harris in Islam in the future
of tolerance these burly guys hate
Islamists they hate jamaat-e-islami in
Pakistan they despise these limits they
they hate them more than they'd hate a
non-practicing muslim' definitely right
and I know this is my community I know
inside out you know if I was just an
ordinary non devout Muslim the brevity's
would still have no problem with me yeah
well what's the reason for that hatred
because I think the average person
listening to you know wait a minute
buying because I see then aren't they
they see it they see Islamism as an
innovation in religious terms a heresy
right and so it would be very easy for a
Braley voice to appear to the outside
world as a reforming liberal secular you
know and this is where I'm going with
this right yeah if you didn't know where
that person was coming from it would be
easy to assume that because they're
everything they're saying against Islam
it's in public that they are with you
but you've got to know this community
inside out to know that the one area
that you will lose the bro beyond and
this is why I would lose them is because
I I tweeted out cartoon of the Prophet
Mohammed the one thing that railways
cannot tolerate is blasphemy they are
Sufis who love the Prophet
in a mystical spiritual way and that
love has translated into a passion - a
passion right and so it was the relevant
that murdered the Governor of Punjab not
the community voices from within the
community who murdered the Governor of
Punjab Salman Taseer in Pakistan who
merely called for reforming the
blasphemy law hmm his own bodyguard shot
him to death nine times and his own
bodyguard was from the Braille resect
that I've just mentioned and these guys
would die fighting the Islamists and yet
on blasphemy they've some of them have
turned into murderers and many of them
now are singing the praises of that
murderer so I give this example to show
you that you've got to know the
community inside out to know where a
voice is coming from now take the second
example here from a different sect the
Shia sect there is an equivalent
let's take Iraq where there are many she
I think 60% of Iraqi Shia there's the
Sistani style Shia in Iraq who were
devoutly avowedly secular and therefore
will openly criticize the Iranian regime
mm-hmm but you can understand these are
still ultra conservative religious
people and so their critique of Islamism
in public even Shia Islam ISM in the
form of Iran and Hezbollah isn't the
whole story and so all I'm saying and I
doubt as I repeat I do know Amanda Heidi
all I'm saying is we've got to
understand the internal dynamics here to
know where voices are kind that's oh I'm
so glad you explained it that way
because that's exactly why I was having
hesitancy here not if Faisal do it I'll
gladly do it because at some level we
all can only learn so much about
everything I and just when you have a
new person it's just kind of it's just a
new x-pac yeah yeah absolutely yeah but
it's a good thing you voices are merging
yeah yeah it's it's always good because
that means the conversations moving
forward yeah yeah what was the part that
you just wanted to get balance oh I'm
just saying um I don't know if you will
have time for this but I have as much
time as you want I wanted to give you a
chance for a nap before yeah well yeah
I'm not back till 6:00 a.m. this morning
but I'm I was just saying there's a
confusion around people are asking me
increasingly how do we know the
difference between a reforming Muslim
and an apologist and what is the
difference between Muslim fundamentalism
and Islamism because is it is Islamism
really Islam you know there's a bit of a
using around these three areas you know
and so I was I said I'm happy to speak
and I just have I just told you ask your
own question that's a great good some
bad
have fun so yeah okay so I think I think
um that was a great trip
yeah a great little trick you did there
you drop the head they may ask yourself
myself yeah I could ask Mike well it's
go but it actually is a nice segue from
the last thing yeah I think it's
important for people to know this
because increasingly as more and more
reformers live voices will emerge and
some of them will be jumping on the
bandwagon and others will be genuine
we've got to know this difference we've
got to know what is the difference
between somebody who's attempting to
engage in apologetics for Islam while
using the language of reform and
somebody's genuinely trying to reform
this discourse yeah can we pause there
for a second so in my opinion but please
challenge me if you hadn't come in
correct I would argue Linda Sarsour is
is in that camp the first camp yeah yeah
I mean I again I've never met her or
spoken so I know she's been attacking up
never I've never spoken to her but but
yeah I mean that that's an example so
somebody from Zampa who says Islam has
always been feminist and will be
feminist and and there's no problem with
FGM it's an African problem you know
some of the invention that yeah even
easy has got the greatest rights in the
world for Muslims and normals is there
that kind of discussion right because a
reformer will also end up having to come
to the position that Islam keep in mind
if there are reforming Muslim they
haven't left the religion so in the end
for them to be a reforming liberal
Muslim they're going to have to have
come to the conclusion that Islam is
compatible with feminism and so it's a
beautiful example what is the difference
between a reforming Muslim who comes to
the conclusion they've reconciled their
Islam with feminism and an apologist who
says Islam is feminist and always has
been and how do we know the difference
so lots of people be asking me that
that's yeah it's important for me to
elaborate okay may I you please do okay
thank you right so I think the key that
one of the one of the most important
things to know that if I could probably
just leave the room for a little haze
yeah one of the most important things it
there in that in recognizing that
difference off from the get-go is a
reforming Muslim will begin by
acknowledging there's a problem and an
apologist
will pretend there isn't a problem never
has
yeah and that's the key thing first off
from the from the off the bat you know
from the get-go a reforming Muslim will
say yes there's a problem not only in
our communities with not only the rise
of Islam ISM but also the rise of Muslim
fundamentalism and not the same thing
they are related but they're not the
same thing
so the brevity example I gave that's an
example of Muslim fundamentalism they
hate the Islamists but they're still
fundamentalist in their own way with
blasphemy so a reforming ones will
acknowledge those two problems and
Muslim fundamentalism and Islamism
within the community I will also
acknowledge a problem scripture from the
Gecko a reforming Muslim if they don't
acknowledge a problem with Scripture not
aren't reforming much to be just you
know so reformed yusin will say yes we
have problematic traditions whether it's
the hadith that says whoever changes is
religion killing it's it's there it's in
the scripture or passages in the Quran
that talk about lashing the fornicator
or chopping off the hand of a thief and
so on and so forth these or beating
one's wife which I recently challenged
somebody to on my OBC show quoting to
them the Arabic and you know it's clear
it's there of a father reborn right so
we this is beat them talking about what
this is in the Quran so reforming ISM
will acknowledge there are problematic
passages in the scripture and that that
there are problems in the community with
how they view this scripture and then
we'll begin attempting to reconcile and
reform that discourse and say now we
acknowledge there's a problem how do we
fix it whereas the apologist will not
recognize a problem in the community nor
with the scripture and will instead
appropriate the language of social
justice to conceal that problem with a
view to diverting attention away to
elsewhere what do you think the
apologist is trying to do so when I hear
Sarsour or even Reza who sort of danced
around without saying thing but some of
these people but particularly Sarsour I
agree it's been it's now become this
intersectional crazy thing with all the
SJW stuff and all that but what do you
think she's really trying to do because
if I advance the interest of a / so
that's so that fundamentalism is obvious
because it no it seems very obvious to
me but again I try not to impugn
everyone's intentions but she to me it
seems like she's
you can ask them a question very simple
you know I've known for asking these
difficult to get out of questions yeah
and they say you know do you do you care
for are you interested in advancing the
interests of Islam
you know if somebody asked me that
question I'll be honest and say - I'm
not religious you know I don't even
think there's a first time ever I'm
gonna be saying it's on it's actually
people are giving us the grace of
overextending time yeah I'm gonna hear
now something for the first time I don't
believe that there should be is or need
be in Muslim theological terms a
difference between Muslim and non-muslim
it no longer makes sense to me and what
I mean by that is historically I meant
to say that that Muslim is my brother
and you're a non-muslim right he will
always be and she will always be my
brother and sister in Islam over you
who's Dave my friend whatever but
they're my brothers in faith you know
that distinction of even calling so on
and Muslim in a normal sin is no longer
relevant if indeed it ever was and what
I mean by that is you're a better human
being then a Muslim who believes in
blasphemy laws in killing gays and
whatever they believe in right you're a
better human being than that person so
you're more my brother than they are
right and so I think it's important it's
important to put that out there that if
you ask me I do I believe in furthering
the interests of Islam you can see the
answer there's like no I believe in
furthering the interests of humanity
yeah you know and Islam as a religion as
it was constructed by men but furthering
the interest of that is essentially
furthering the interests of medieval ism
but this is what I believe apologists
are interested in furthering the
interests of a medieval structure that
was ended up called being called the
religion of Islam and it's important to
recognize that because Sheikh Osama
husband was at Quilliam as a as a
reformed imam if you think about him
he's engaged in the theological debate
and so the poor guy he has no choice but
to say I've reconciled my religion with
feminism yeah otherwise by definition he
wouldn't be a reformer right so we've
got to give him that leeway to do that
if we pragmatically recognize the
importance of the reform project while
recognizing he's no Linda Sarsour or you
know personalize it forgive me whoever
yeah the other person is he he's no that
person you know
yeah yeah oh that makes it clear for
people I just I thought that was
important because you will get more and
more people saying yeah they believe in
reform their liberal Muslims and we just
need to have an understanding as to how
to begin to filter through that well I
think what you're doing extremely well
is that you're taking your logic to the
end you're you know I mean you're trying
not to get to a place where you're going
to be on stage one day and then one is
going to go well Majid I hear you I hear
you here we've gotten here but how you
have this this unanswerable question and
I don't sense that I sense that you know
you've laid the ground for now I'm gonna
be honest with people you know that's
the important thing again that the key
thing is to be honest in these
conversations because you know people
people are seeing and then noticing a
lack of honesty and it's refreshing for
people to have a Muslim is gonna speak
openly honestly about this stuff yeah
all right I'm gonna let you go yeah I
know you could do more look I'm feeling
we're gonna do this again yeah yeah I
think so yeah who do these again either
here or and we'll ask your viewers to
watch they want more watch Bill Maher's
real time Oh watch real time tonight and
we're going out to dinner with Santana
can we not talk about Islam yeah yeah
let's do that yeah yeah yeah well you're
not a basketball Gary not that big no I
can tell you our music films Oh Star
Wars we'll do star lots of stuff just
actress yet American sports forgive me
man you know all right I don't know I
don't know I don't know what talking
about there all right well thank you for
doing this this was totally last second
- and and you Shepherd yeah yeah
watch out from major announcement on
Bill Maher sure oh I saw you teased a
little major I'm surprised you asked me
about oh okay I'm gonna say no I'm not
going to tell you but you did ask me so
I didn't even need to say no you asked
yourself the right questions and I
forgot the questions that I should ask
you all right it really it's been a
pleasure thank you dick and catch mojit
tonight on real time which is 10 p.m.
Eastern on HBO if you haven't cut the
cord yet or maybe you have HBO now or
whatever it is and this was a crazy week
here we did three live streams we did a
regular show and it is fully because of
you guys hooking us up on patreon and
supporting what we do so I thank you as
always and have a good weekend
[Music]
you